it is Monday and it's the beginning of
the third week of quarantine I am
broadcasting as always these days from
my home in Los Angeles hope you had a
decent weekend yesterday was Easter I
don't know who among you celebrate
Easter I know a bunch of you do I was
raised very Catholic so yes yes
Easter is a big deal for me yesterday I
celebrated the resurrection of Jesus and
I also celebrated the fact that I didn't
have to go to Mass yeah yeah finally
getting to see what it's like to be a
piss cup alien you know no one's ever
said Episcopalian quite like that and no
one ever will again it's just too stupid
what else is going on yesterday I got a
big shock yesterday I found out that my
darling daughter no longer believes in
the Easter Bunny yeah yeah I read it in
an email from one of her professors
she's 48 look I think these are top
quality top quality Easter jokes I don't
want to hear any complaints from any of
you okay
and how you gonna get to me anyway I'm
not reading emails done in my house
wrapped in delusion like velvet